[Music]
guys csgo can get pretty serious
sometimes round by round decision by
decision the stress is real I mean do we
eco do we go aggressive should we stack
a site should I buy head armor or names
oh it's all too much sometimes
that's why occasionally you've just got
to chill out and buy that shotgun I mean
I know about you but to me nothing
lightens the mood in a server like a
good old XM rush that's right guys get
pumped up see what I did there
this week we're taking a look at the top
10 shotgun kills in csgo kicking off our
list at number 10 is clg's hazed who
pulled off an incredible feat during ESL
esea Pro League season 1 looking to
build up some money for the next round
against Team Liquid haze puts his trusty
shotgun to good use by mowing down
tl-one terrorists after another looking
to come out Eric's gonna come under fire
what does he have for us
and now the Nova haze hi 1 2 & 3 he's
gonna go for the peak he's gotta Drinan
logs he's gonna try to pop some shots on
the fugly takes him down as well could
it be a shotgun a so feel it for 6 he
got the ACE plus one he's a guy tag
you're not stealing my dad that's what
happens when you try to steal a man's
ace you get punished
coming in at number nine we have TSM's
device who with his team in the lead
decided to take down most of Penta
eSports in style device though I mean
speaking of wrecking he's got the old
man gun he's roasting a little bit here
so he's got to be careful just waiting
for somebody to commit around that
corner there it is boom headshot oh
don't don't give him more kills nice
give him more money
that's a nice one yes the sort of run
back in so I mean it's a nice pop flash
but it is better someone else could do
it second kill kill Nova's shotgun gonna
be shutting down almost all depends on
here the semi range it's a quad kill
pick some of your meat no you can today
yeah you're gonna have to recommit to it
you want that Nova ace I don't think
we've ever really had that before speed
ease come around the corner here device
o6y come on man I just think about the
money that dice just made right now yeah
up to 7 grand
why sip nice ah that would have been
beautiful no really device man to lack
of respect right now and we had a no
vase ever don't think so now next up on
our list is get right who pulled off a
jaw-dropping
ace against natus Vincere during
fragbite masters of 2014 using the mag-7
to its fullest on train get right
decimates the CIS squad proving that no
matter what weapons you give him the
swedish legend will make it work lot of
them give right
[ __ ] my shoulder I just managed game get
the writers comment on this shitty stuff
oh boy are you all what does a double
get rise
who says flicks are just for ops coming
in at number seven is God since toplin
who at ESL pro league season six proved
that shotgun flicks are just as sick
with envy already on cashes be site da
plan found himself trapped with a liam
mag-7 in hand but of course you didn't
see it that way be it in once again and
this is where the shotgun really comes
into play
stepping out a check is one the
long-range pellets missing with the spin
and the flick nice and quick
I thought you're gonna say something the
left to be in it then but you didn't you
kept together but nothing spells
confidence more than running through a
Mali with the shaadi which is why
flusher coming on vexed gaming during
Star Series season 14 fnatic found
themselves with a commanding lead and
with the round coming to an end flush
had decided it was time to go hunting as
he works his way up the staircase
Hermann X finds another one Tuesday a
flanker back over there from Beck's is
taken out and there's flush again with
another shot from the mag-7 that shotgun
pretty long-range kill too when you
consider it but it's gonna work out and
the Molly comes in burning the bodies
alive but he's gonna run through the
Molly mixed up another one where's the
call from hyper hyper didn't realize it
bushes Rosen gets another 4k holy crap
I'd imagine at this point you might be
getting tired of the mag-7 well we're
not since time and time again pros have
been able to pop off heads and make it
flashy that's no different here with NBK
showing us just how versatile he is as a
player and unfortunately for Dignitas
they'd be used as the demonstration
dummies let's go and BK is shutting down
the entire offensive easily that rounds
done for n BK with a 4k of max 7 at
number 4 we have fanatics olofmeister at
ESL one cologne 2014 on the cusp of
losing the map to virtus pro the swedes
needed to come up with some sort of
brilliant play to save themselves so
what better than letting olofmeister
live up to his famous Olaf past nickname
is actually a crimson Olaf Oberth
holding him but that's what they've been
doing every time and Crim's is gonna be
in that hut beep you're gonna run into
that Hut they're gonna give a freebie d
Crim's all those snacks bears stephane
Cruz first all finds them with the chop
big spikes drops triple kill for all off
a bit of a pat on the shoulder from the
coach dead yet the young walked really
congratulating him on that one that was
very very cool shotguns are big guns so
we thought the number three spot on our
list should be held by the man with the
biggest guns in cs:go
most players don't like taking too many
risks with their money during the
semi-final of a major but then again
most players aren't passionate biceps
and at ESL one cologne 2016
Pasha used a mag 7 to remind SK gaming
exactly why VP Ark Encounter strike oh
jeez ok he said fashion was good with
these jokers I didn't expect anything
like that three kills from free stuff
that's pretty insane is it actually
possible to be sneaky with a shotgun
well apparently tizian thought so and
wanted to prove it against drugs Vella
eSports in ESL's Meister shop League
already ahead five rounds tizian decided
to change things up and buy a nova
before putting on his best Stewie 2k
impression and kindly showing druks
Vella the power of his boomstick thanks
to be $1,800 he followed on the back of
the Umba 3k now can buy himself an old
but now in the smoke and would speed
look at what's his ins doing they don't
know he's here to get water gonna go for
the second it's well he did so much
damage looking for it done dizzy and
what are you doing that's indeed what
was that
that was insane that was so much fun as
well that's what Counter Strike is all
about taking the number-one spot with
his second appearance on this list is
Swedish legend get right who scored an
unbelievable ace against C play at North
Kahn 2012 with everyone still trying to
figure out the ins and outs of csgo few
players knew what weapons to expect when
it came to an eco round so with no armor
against a full buy get right went on to
set the standard for what makes a great
gun play
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please update on the night segment and
I'm no afraid to use this that was one
of the most impressive well guys that is
our list of the top ten shotgun kills in
csgo now look if you're looking for more
venomous gaming athleticism be sure to
check out our story of doctor disrespect
that's dropping this Saturday that's all
for me though guys and I will see you
next time thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button